en el siguiente sistema de ecuaciones x
+ 2
13 3 x igual a menos 11 el punto menos
17 este punto que tenemos aquí es
solución del sistema y bueno sí este
punto es solución del sistema eso quiere
decir que cuando x vale menos 1 lo voy a
poner así x vale menos 1 entonces que
debe de valer 7 y se tiene que cumplir
ambas ecuaciones tanto la primera como
la segunda se deben de cumplir las dos
ecuaciones simultáneamente para que sean
solución del sistema y bueno pues vamos
a probarlo pero para eso déjame poner
aquí lo que estamos pidiendo estamos
pidiendo que x sea igual a menos 1 en
estas dos ecuaciones que tengo aquí ya
su vez y a su vez aunque james que james
sea igual a 7
ok pues vamos a sustituir a x x menos 1
y hay 10 x 7 en estas dos ecuaciones
vamos a trabajar con él
para ver qué nos sale de sustituir estos
dos valores y que puede obtener bueno
déjenme cambiar de color lo voy a hacer
con color rojo de la primera ecuación
tengo
x + 2 james ok x pero x vale menos 1
entonces me va a quedar menos 1 menos
uno más dos veces y más dos veces pero
llévale a 7 entonces menos 1 lo voy a
poner con este color por dos veces siete
por dos veces 7 esto dice que debe de
ser igual a 13 debe de ser igual a 13
vamos a ver si llegamos a este resultado
y bueno aquí tengo menos uno menos 1 + +
2 por 7 pero 2 por 7 es lo mismo que 14
14 y esto debe de ser igual a 13 ok
y bueno si ahora sumamos menos 1 + 14
esto me da 13 es decir que 13 13 es
exactamente igual que 13 y en este caso
si se cumple para x igual a menos 1 y 7
es decir para el punto menos 17
podemos decir que satisface la primera
ecuación
ten cuidado satisface la primera
ecuación pero eso no quiere decir que
forzosamente satisfaga la segunda
ecuación de hecho es justo lo que vamos
a trabajar ahorita la segunda ecuación
para ver si también este punto es
solución de esta segunda ecuación pero
bueno por ahorita nos ponemos contentos
porque si satisface la primera ecuación
vamos a trabajar con la segunda y con la
segunda me gusta utilizar este color con
este color ok y dice 3x menos esto debe
ser igual a menos 11 y voy a sustituir a
x x menos 1 y allí por 7
entonces me quedaría 33 x x pero x vale
menos 1 entonces 3 que multiplica a
menos 1 esto - james esto menos o espera
déjame ponerlo con el mismo color
- jeff pero ya vale 7 menos 7
esto me debe de dar exactamente lo mismo
que menos 11 esto debe de ser igual a
menos 11 ok pues vamos a multiplicar y
dice 3 x menos 1 es menos 3 menos 7 esto
debe de ser igual
-11 ok pero menos 37 es lo mismo que
menos diez menos diez esto es lo mismo
que menos once y esto no es cierto no se
cumple esto cuando yo me fijo en menos
10 igual a menos 11 eso no es cierto por
lo tanto quiere decir que cuando x vale
menos 1 no y cuando llegue vale 7 no
satisface la segunda ecuación o dicho de
otra manera el punto menos 17 no
satisface la segunda ecuación y como
necesitábamos que se cumplieran las dos
ecuaciones simultáneamente para que
fuera la solución del sistema entonces
podemos decir que este punto el menos 17
no es solución del sistema porque cumple
la primera ecuación pero no cumple la
segunda ecuación entonces podemos
responder que no
no es solución no es solución del
sistema muy bien